european union is reportedly set to
reopen its borders to visitors from more
than a dozen countries but guess what
Americans would not be included than
that that's because of the stark
contrast that you see right here while
most of Europe has successfully reduced
new cases of the corona virus America's
numbers continue to climb and we are not
welcome in Europe Holly Williams has our
report from Athens here in Greece
they're famous for their hospitality and
in this ancient land the modern economy
depends on tourists but with lockdowns
now just a memory and Europe reopening
its doors to tourists from around the
world people coming from the US have
reportedly been deemed too high-risk
Greece's Health Minister told us the
European Union has decided there are
simply too many new infections every day
in the u.s. we're hoping that the
situation is going to be better in a few
days or weeks so this these consents you
want to welcome people here from the
United States but the infection rate has
to come down first something that
everybody can understand it's logical
the Greek authorities will do thousands
of random tests every day at airports
and border crossings and testing teams
have even been sent to far-flung islands
after taking tough measures early Greece
has had remarkable success in combating
the new coronavirus and it doesn't want
to jeopardize it around 200 people have
been killed by Cobra 19 here in Greece
but to put that in perspective it's
about 20 lives lost for every million
people compared to the United States
with around 400 lives lost for every
million people dr. Elena Kaka Lu who
treats co-lead patients in Greece told
us her advice on staying safe this
summer is clear as a health official I
would consider that the best thing
everybody should do would be no
international travel at all for the
yeah Greece's capital city Athens was
named for Athena the ancient Greek
goddess of wisdom whether the decision
to open up to tourists will ultimately
prove to be a wise one is something
we'll only know for sure in the months
to come
50 BS this morning Holly Williams in
Athens Greece